we got this dog man
i like to smoke weed when i walk my dog
i also like to smoke weed when i don't
walk my dog
but i'm out high walking my dog one
night and um
and uh so my dog is a weird he's a weird
pooper
i don't know if does anybody have a
pitbull blending a green hair
pickle and so does he does he poop
normal like on flat ground
yeah yeah okay
she just stares at you that's all dogs
do i think they all stare at you which
is really prison [ __ ] you know what i
mean you know
you're eyeballing someone you're taking
a [ __ ] you're like that's right keep
looking
but i will tell you something you know
um
my dog first of all it's always weird
when i walk him because he doesn't poop
normal he
he first there's only three places he'll
poop he'll be a poop on top of a
giant rock is his favorite one if he can
find a giant rock he will pull me over
there
get to the very edge of it like [ __ ]
simba just
and [ __ ]
it's so weird and then when he poops on
a rock nowhere else he walks around it a
couple times
the other two places he'll poop is he'll
poop up a tree
up he puts his feet his back hinds
up against and he lifts his ass up
so his fronts are off the ground his
butthole is against the tree
and he poops so it sticks to the tree
it's the craziest the first time i saw
him do it i'm like are you [ __ ] like
what are you doing
he shits up trees and then he looks at
it like
well you take a picture of everything
else you're not going to take a picture
of that
my favorite place where he poops and
this is my wife and i both call him the
bush pooper
he poops on bushes
his favorite thing is to find a little
bush and poop on top of it like it like
it's like a
topping of a sundae or something but
what i think is his like mischievous
part of him
is when he poops in the bush the bigger
bush he'll put his butt
in there and and when he you know how
pickles smile
so he'll poop in the bush and smile at
me like
are you gonna put your hand in here and
pick this up huh
and so one night he shits in the bush
and um and by the way i'm with you on
note i don't do
a lot of impersonation guys let me give
you my one impersonation that i do do
i said dude um here's an impersonation
of me
trying to decide if i'm going to pick up
my dog's poop in a bunch
right this is me
if i don't see anybody i know i'm not
picking up that [ __ ] that's how that
goes right
so [ __ ] that i'm not working for it you
know if it's on the ground
fine but i'm not rolling up my sleeves
so
i look i see someone i know i'm like
damn it i reach in the bush and i'm high
i pick it up
throw it away i start to walk down the
street
and i'm about 20 minutes from my house
and i just itch my ear a little bit
oh it gets so much worse
and i'm like do i have ear wax in my ear
and i take my finger out and there's a
little bit of poop because when i guess
when i reach in the bush i get a little
poop on my finger
now i want you to think about how
you scratch your ear do you caress it
you don't know you know what you do you
jam you
jam i jammed dog [ __ ] into my head i
jammed it if i had tried to push it in
harder i couldn't
i jammed dog [ __ ] into my ear like i was
trying to do it
right and so guys my paranoia i'm high
so my paranoia is like
you know i can feel the worm swimming to
my brain i'm like oh
i'm about to die like i assigned myself
20 minutes to live i'm like i got 20
minutes to live you know
so i start to walk home and i'm in
guys i almost dialed 9-1-1 by the way
but would have been the most
embarrassing 9-1-1 call ever like
9-1-1 what's your emergency yeah
abduction
all right we're going to let you go now
there's a google search on my phone it
just says it's dog [ __ ]
bad for your brain
we don't know the answer to that
question that's so stupid
but so the only thing that i knew that
was working still guys was gravity
so i started walking down the street
like this walking my dog
and i'm walking through my neighborhood
i'm trying to get home 20 minutes to
live
and i come up on this dude's house and
he's in his front yard
he's watering the yard he's got a mask
on
8 30 at night mask on water in the yard
now guys
during this past year we've been asked
to choose from pretty
two stupid teams about this whole
pandemic team it's totally fake
and team we're all gonna die and i'm
here to tell you there's a lot of room
in the middle for smart people you know
what i mean
but i will tell you this this dude in
the middle of his own lawn
8 30 at night with a mask on
he's on team we're all gonna die you
know and so
the last thing he wants to see is my
[ __ ] dumb ass walking up to
walking up to his house you know and so
he's watering his lawn and he's like
what's going on and i was like i need to
use your hose
and he goes why and i was like like a
dog [ __ ] in my arm
he laid the hose down he walked over to
his phone he picked it up and he leaned
on his house and he goes
have at it
and i said i would really prefer if you
didn't film this and he said oh i bet
you would
and he goes i go you still don't film it
man even though i asked you not to film
it anyways let me ask you something
stranger showed up at your house in the
middle of the night
and had dog [ __ ] in your ear
and said they wanted to wash it out in
your front yard you wouldn't film it
and i was like well not if he asked me
not to and he goes yeah well that's the
price of a mission you want to use the
hose or not
i'm like yeah i want to use the hose man
he goes cool and so
i pick up the hose and i have my i'm
going to put my thumb over and shoot the
water into my ear right
water here done right and he goes
what's the plan it's your strategy and i
go i'm gonna shoot the water into my
hair
and wash it out he goes oh okay because
you're not scared you're
gonna shoot the [ __ ] further into your
head
[Applause]
okay
and his son comes to the window of the
house and he goes who's that
and he goes oh it's just a friend i need
to use a house
and he goes why does he use those
[Applause]
[Music]
oh